in the Phuket mountain range on the
central coast of Vietnam these men of
the first Air Cavalry Division have just
captured a Vietcong during Operation
Washington Irving it is 10 October and
these troops are working their way
northward toward the village of Fumi
their orders are to search the area
enroute and to pacify the village when
it is reached here in the coastal
mountain range 40 kilometers northeast
of anche a cooling stream offers an
opportunity to refill their canteens
while security guards cover them some of
the troopers take time out for a
refreshing bath in the stream then the
move up begins again the operation now
in its second phase has been going on
since early in September during that
time the sky troopers have killed more
than 400 Vietcong and captured tons of
rice medical supplies weapons and
ammunition
now another hamlet lies just ahead and
the approach is made with caution
the same familiar pattern a nameless
collection of huts somewhere in the
jungle and the job is to search and
probe ferreting out an enemy who may be
hidden in any Hut cellar tunnel or
bunker when a camouflaged bunker is
discovered in the woods nearby
a hand grenade is tossed into the dark
opening leaving the deserted group of
huts behind the men press on toward the
village of Fumi
the sweep northward takes the troopers
across well-tended rice fields
arriving at Fumi the air cavalrymen find
the village unoccupied a house-to-house
search is conducted from one of the
dwellings comes a pair of canvas bags in
these a mysterious diagram an ammunition
clip and a folder containing DC identity
papers a member of the Vietcong lived
here security patrols surprise and
capture another Vietcong while searching
the surrounding hills soon the villagers
come out of hiding and this woman is
detained when it is reported that she is
a communist Informer married to a
Vietcong when questioned her statements
conflict with reports of her activities
to determine the truth about this
innocent-looking mother with two
children she is escorted to another part
of the village where a command post has
been established in one of the buildings
she has allegedly stopped the farmers
from harvesting their crops by
intimidating them with threats of
Vietcong reprisals as the sky troopers
settle down to the job of pacification
the villagers join the chow line
as a Marine unit moves out to support
fighting near the DMZ and artillery
battery from the 173rd Airborne Brigade
takes over at an emplacement five
kilometres north of Da Nang the men and
their guns were flown in by c-130 from
Benoit on the preceding day and made the
last leg of the journey by convoy a
kilometer is set up as the job of
readying the 105 millimeter howitzers
for action begins working quickly and
efficiently the men check out their
weapons thoroughly all moving parts are
cleaned and oiled mud and dirt are
scrubbed from the recoil spring and
frame behind a wall of sandbags the
battery sets up its fire Direction
Control Center it is ready and waiting
when the first call for support comes in
grid coordinates are taken and
deflection and quadrant computed then
the battery is notified to zero in they
lose no time swinging into action as the
fire mission is called out shells are
rapidly prepared for firing deflection
is set through the panoramic telescope
the guns are elevated and shells slammed
into the breech of each howitzer finally
the fire command is given and the
battery begins bracketing in on its
first target
it is 11 October and members of the
Joint Army Air Force Task Force Eagle
are being flown 25 kilometers northeast
of thon wrong for a mission investigate
the cause of an air crash nine days ago
an Air Force c-130 flying from Thanh
salute airbase to Cam Ranh Bay crashed
into the side of a thousand kilometer
mountain it's five-man crew are the only
personnel on board and none survived now
the Joint Task Force lands on an LZ 400
metres below the mountains top and a
wearying climb begins the army element
consists of members of a support
battalion of the 101st Airborne Division
it's basic mission is to take the Air
Force teams to the crash site and to
provide security throughout the
operation intelligence reports that
accompany sized Vietcong unit is in the
area the air force element consists of
an investigation team an explosive
ordnance disposal team and a medical
team at the top of the mountain the men
hack out an LZ large enough for an H 43
husky which will evacuate the bodies
word is transmitted that the LZ is ready
as security troops and the DoD team
descend the other side of the mountain
to the crash site the H 43 makes its
approach to the LZ while at the scene of
the crash jagged pieces of metal in the
underbrush mutely testified to the
violent impact that suddenly blasted
these quiet hills nine days ago nothing
is left intact
neither men nor aircraft all that can be
done is to gather information that may
help prevent similar accidents in the
future
US Defense Secretary Robert S McNamara
arrives at Danang airfield following two
days of top-secret briefings and a
meeting with the enemy's government
officials on October 10 and 11 in Saigon
now on a tour of American bases the
defense secretary is accompanied by
General William C Westmoreland commander
of US forces in Vietnam and a party of
Vietnamese dignitaries including general
know Andrew Cole defense minister of the
Republic a short helicopter flight from
Danang airfield carries the secretary
and his party to marine headquarters at
Dong Ha at the base mr. McNamara meets
with the press following the interviews
he is briefed on marine operations at
the DMZ the fact-finding continues as
the secretary is taken to the helipad
for a flight over the DMZ aboard a ch-47
Chinook helicopter the official party
observes the results of US air strikes
in the Demilitarized Zone in recent
weeks this buffer zone separating North
and South Vietnam has become a major
battlefield as enemy troops have
violated the DMZ by using it as a
staging area and as a route of
infiltration to the south when
discovered the Communist enemy has been
hit by dozens of sorties flown by US
aircraft on the ground American marines
have defended the corridor and hurled
the invaders back in Operation Prairie
the US Army 25th Infantry Division
Headquarters at Khushi is also visited
by the Secretary of Defense this base
located 32 kilometers northwest of
Saigon was a barren brush covered plain
less than a year ago
upon arrival secretary McNamara is taken
to the headquarters conference room for
a briefing on the divisions activities
the conference concluded mr. McNamara
and the official party are driven to the
traffic lightning divisions airfield
where they are to board another
helicopter visiting dignitaries of the
Saigon government hold informal
discussions with the American military
leaders at the airfield as the defense
secretary takes his seat in the
helicopter
once again the defense chief will
observe ground operations from the air
throughout his flying visit to the
various US units in Vietnam mr. McNamara
was updated on the tactical situation at
Phu cut in the second core area troopers
of the first Air Cavalry Division are
engaged in operation Irving the Defense
Secretary observes firsthand this
forward area outpost under heavy
security with the situation fully
reported mr. McNamara departs
the first logistical command is
responsible for supplying fresh fruit
and vegetables to US troops in Vietnam
the food is purchased by bid from local
farmers in the De La area this method of
procurement stabilizes the local economy
and helps the people to support
themselves
aside from bringing many new fields
under cultivation new industries such as
the construction of wooden produce
crates have been developed crated
produce is trucked to the railhead at
the lot where it will be shipped by
priority first to hospitals then combat
troops and finally support troops
members of the inventory control center
check the shipment for quality and
weight then the produce is loaded into
boxcars when repairs are completed on
the dalat airstrip rail movement will be
eliminated at Phan rung the shipment is
open and loaded onto a truck for the
short trip to the airfield
the first logistical command is now in
the process of expanding its operation
to include purchasing in the Saigon and
later the delta areas of vietnam
purchases are also being made in Japan
Taiwan the Philippines and the United
States
this signal based fo just outside Saigon
operates under the guidance of the
Army's McVie advisory program here such
items as radio teletypes photo equipment
switchboards field phones transmitters
and generators are rebuilt for further
use by Armed Forces on duty in Vietnam
they are stacked according to type as
they await repair US advisor sergeant
Alfonzo Hildreth examines a broken piece
of equipment each unit is completely
disassembled and cleaned the actual
salvage operation then begins with an
adjustment of the mechanical controls
wherever needed new parts are installed
these are electrically aligned to their
proper settings then the all-important
bench testing is conducted in another
area the cases are sanded down to bare
metal
they are then repainted and dried and
the case and the unit itself are
reassembled finally the completed sets
are tallied to await quality control
calibration and distance tests
at the seventieth medical base depo
Saigon American army advisor Chief
Warrant Officer Francis a boss fair
discusses the replacement of a piece of
equipment with a Vietnamese medical
repair man
since the equipment is american-made and
the instructions are printed in English
our advisors find that demonstration is
the key to success here
Staff Sergeant Laurence T zero looks
then to see how the work is going the
Vietnamese language has few words for
modern technology because of this
frequent explanation on the part of our
advisors is required the repaired
medical and dental equipment is then
crated and stored in warehouses for
shipment from the depot to points
throughout Vietnam elsewhere on the base
the advisory program continues at this
the only pharmaceutical Center in
Vietnam these glass ampules are being
filled with quinine for me a flames heat
the tips and the ampules are sealed last
year nearly a million and a half ampules
of drugs were manufactured and
distributed from here afterwards they
are labeled and inspected then
individually packed for shipment this
chalk like substance will soon reappear
in the more familiar shape of a pill
pills to fit every need are turned out
at the rate of 800,000 a month solutions
and ointments are mixed in vats such as
these Major John Hunter rec senior
adviser goes over the production figures
with his Vietnamese counterpart
Vaughn wrong Vietnam 10 October
Lieutenant General million fan - chief
of state Vietnam arrives for the
presentation of gifts to American and
Korean forces in the fund wrong area a
motorcade passed a joint American and
Korean honor guard takes the general and
his party to the Air Force Base where he
meets Brigadier General Willard Pearson
commanding general 1st Brigade 101st
Airborne Division and his staff
general Phan - delivers a short speech
of appreciation from the leaders and the
people of Vietnam to the American and
Korean forces and then presents gifts to
each of the officers in attendance
the presentation is followed by
refreshments and a brief period of
socializing the amenities at an end
general fan - and his staff depart for
Saigon
you